hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse or en comm and today i'm going to
demonstrate for you how to take a manual
blood pressure using the two-step method
in my previous video I showed you how to
take a regular manual blood pressure
using the one-step but today we're going
to take a little bit further and do the
two-step method people like to use the
two-step method because they feel it's a
little bit more accurate here I have our
patient which is my husband who has been
so nice to let me take his blood
pressure and what we're going to do is
we're going to have him in a sitting
position and make sure his arm his upper
arm is level with his heart and have his
palms turn outward so we can expose and
get up to that upper arm we're going to
get our blood pressure cuff you always
want to make sure that it fits your
patient because you can get an
inaccurate reading if it doesn't fit the
rule of thumb is be sure you can get two
fingers underneath the cuff snugly not
loosely not too tight so we're going to
slide it up his arm and let's feel where
the brachial artery is it's usually in
the bend of the arm and on this in the
inside and just feel where that is and
wherever you feel it put your cuff 1 to
2 inches above where you feel it and
there's these little arrows on the cuff
and that just helps guide you so we're
going to go about right there and always
be sure to clip your Spig a moment
ometer up there in your eye and your eye
level so you can see what the reading is
and there's usually a little spot you
can clip it now what we're going to do
is we're going to feel with our
non-dominant hand the brachial artery
and we are going to inflate the cuff
until we no longer feel the artery this
will be our systolic pressure so let's
do that
ok we're pumping it up and I'm feeling
on the artery and I no longer feel about
the 102 mark so now what I want to do is
I want to slowly deflate the cuff and
when I start to not feel it again this
will be our diastolic and I quit feeling
it at 6c so his pressure is 102 over 6
okay fully deflate the cuff and then
we're going to keep the cup on the
patient and wait 30 seconds then we're
going to repeat this procedure but we're
going to do it with our stethoscope
instead of filling for the brachial
artery and we'll compare the two so
let's wait 30 seconds
okay so we've waited 30 seconds now
we're going to take the blood pressure
using our set the scope so make sure
that you turn your mouth to close so you
can blow up the blood pressure cuff and
we're going to take our set the scope
diaphragm or bell whichever one you
choose and put it over where the
brachial artery is and we are going to
blow the cuff up 30 millimeters of
mercury more than what his systolic was
with the last reading so his last
reading was 102 systolic so we're going
to blow it up to 132 okay we're at 132
now we're going to slowly release the
air about two to three millimeters of
mercury
until we hurt here our version weighs
and I'll let you know okay I heard it at
a hundred that's our systolic
and it quit at 60 so his blood pressure
was 100 over 60 fully deflate your cuff
and let the patient know what their
blood pressure was it was 100 over 60
and take the cap off the patient and as
you can see the two-step method is a
very reliable method because we got the
same estimates this first one was 102
over 60 and his next one was 100 over 60
so there you go I hope this helped you
out and please look at my other nursing
skill videos and subscribe to this
YouTube channel thank you so much - have
a great day